allez les cocos
allez
l'histoire depuis 6 ans c'est juste de
m'installer ici pour garer la caravane
on attend trop trouver quelques choses
ou me mettre et puis je me suis
tellement plus ici que j'ai voulu rester
donc je suis resté après l'histoire
c'est c'est juste de m'intégrer dans ce
lieu et puis dire mais ce lieu peut
m'apporter plein de choses pas seulement
de la nourriture du bien-être on m'a
tellement fait croire que je devais être
quelque chose de quelqu'un ou j'ai juste
envie d'être un être vivant c'est quoi
votre monde de ma demande
c'est la vie moi c'est le nôtre et que
chacun crée le sien qui hérisson il
pense
ah non ça va être la cuisine c'est pas
notre cuisine c'est carrément la maison
nous on a une maison qui fait 4 mètres
sur deux je pense pas qu'on pourrait
vivre à trois mais
ça commence à peut-être à se compliquer
on vit dans cet espace qui est assez
petit on va dire mais on vit tellement
dehors
que on n'a pas besoin d'être à
l'intérieur on est très bien ici mais
certains diraient moi je peux pas vivre
comme ça mais c'est pas grave c'est nous
qui vivons là
donc nous ça nous convient et puis
et puis on a la pendule évidemment mais
qu'on ne remonte pas parce que ici le
temps n'existe pas
ça c'est les cuirs en bois que nous on
fait avec le bois d'ici voilà à quoi on
passe nos hivers
cette deuxième caravane sert à quoi
alors c'est une caravane qu'on m'a donné
le devant l'été ça sert de boutique on
fait une petite boutique en plein air on
a les petits articles qu'on vend comme
Myriam photographe à l'écart postales on
a on fabrique des savons des choses
comme ça mais surtout c'est que l'hiver
elle sert de lieu d'accueil pour des
personnes dans le besoin en fait il n'y
a pas vraiment de potager des gain une
place on va mettre une salade par
exemple mais ce qu'on essaye c'est que
de partout un jour il n'y a que des
allées de chaque côté on puisse cueillir
des choses pour se nourrir en toute
saison évidemment lorsqu'on a de
l'abondance ce qu'on va faire c'est que
on va faire de la lacto-fermentation on
va conserver on fait beaucoup de séchage
même des légumes on fait sécher les
légumes ils ont poussé seulement depuis
le printemps les pêches là
et ici on a des péchés des pruniers sont
Joos comme ça et font déjà des fruits
ils ont deux ans
j'ai souvent entendu que pour vivre en
autonomie fallait deux trois hectares 20
hectares ou je ne sais quoi ici on a
8600 mètres carrés toutes les cultures
que l'on fait beaucoup de légumes
perpétuels on peut nourrir quatre
personnes à l'année souvent il y a des
personnes qui ont dit ouais ces gens-là
vivent de d'être social ou je ne sais
quoi non non il en est pas question on a
un budget alimentaire qui est
très faible ça dépend si on a vendu
quelques petits objets ici un petit truc
mais donc du coup on n'est pas
totalement système voilà soyons clairs
personne ne le sera jamais on a le
téléphone par exemple bon il faut bien
payer l'abonnement mais voilà c'est on
pourrait le dire que avec 50 euros on
vit
moi j'ai toujours dit on peut vivre sans
argent à condition d'en avoir eu avant
terrain c'est pas c'est pas volé faut
acheter le terrain quelques outils
acheter la caravane les panneaux
solaires faut avoir de l'argent à partir
de ce moment-là on peut arrêter d'en
faire rentrer il y a des personnes qui
disent ouais j'ai pas envie de vivre
comme eux parce que ça ils ont pas l'air
de d'être très heureux je me suis dit
mais nous tous les gens qu'on rencontre
il dit mais quand vous faites pour avoir
le sourire alors que vous vivez comme ça
avec tout ce que vous avez pourquoi vous
tirez la tronche quoi pas mal de gens
qui ne comprennent pas ta vie je vois
complètement en marche je vois comme un
zozone
un fou des choses comme ça mais c'est
pas depuis que je suis ici ça a toujours
été depuis que je suis enfant déjà
enfant je vivais près de la forêt et
puis dans les années 90 en caravane je
sais qu'il y a des gens qui font des
burnotes et puis qui sont
néo-ruraux je ne sais plus enfin il y a
tout un tas de mots un petit peu à la
mode là je vais pas dire que j'ai
toujours vécu ici ça fait 6 ans que je
suis là mais j'ai toujours vécu de cette
façon m'a montré quand j'étais enfant
cueillir les orties aller ramasser les
champignons les reconnaître Myriam c'est
pareil
au Maroc du coup comme tu finis à Casa
ma grand-mère nous soignait toujours par
les plantes elle s'y connaissait
énormément et donc c'est quelque chose
qui est resté et
toujours essayer d'être
plus dans la nature voilà et puis mes
enfants disent ben tant que tu es
heureuse c'est bon on est heureux
le système il a aussi intégré le progrès
toi tu te situes où par rapport au
progrès il y a de la technologie qui est
là on a des panneaux solaires c'est la
technologie donc on profite aussi de ce
qui a été créé moi c'est pas contre ça
toutes les inventions qui ont été faites
mais j'aimerais bien qu'on revienne
aussi à des inventions qui ont été
faites qui étaient très intéressantes
pour que l'on puisse vivre paisiblement
je suis resté seul pendant 5 ans ici et
c'était pas un choix d'être seul c'était
ça s'est trouvé comme ça et je crois que
c'était une synchronicité il fallait que
ce soit seul un jour on ira m'est passé
comme ça puis elle est revenue elle est
revenue et puis je lui dis bah écoute si
tu veux tu restes et elle m'a regardé du
bois je comptais justement trouver un
petit lieu où planter des arbres faire
plus de jardinage et plus en contact de
la nature et
puis qu'en solo me l'a proposé je dis
bah voilà c'est bon